well first we're going to jump in the
tick-tock time machine going back to
the 90s apartment therapy reports that a
man in
iowa built a retro video
rental store in his basement and he
shared it to her on tick
it's not a business unfortunately we
can't go it's just a fun nostalgic
bunker
for family and friends he did it for his
kids
so i have to say you know being
inspired especially right now when we're
all stuck at home he gets like
the father of the year award because
that is just so incredibly inventive
it's very cool and i would love to go in
and explore i miss
i miss like the blockbuster that kind of
store you know i would do like the music
store remember going to get a cd
oh of course i do by the way i used to
work at a music plus
yeah my boss was named whitney he could
not stand me he was like a total hesher
rocker
he had like the he looked like frampton
you know can i just do it
like a time out like at what point in
your life like when
did i do that like i don't know 12 and i
took the bus to work
and you know i just i wanted to work at
a job and no one was calling me for a
job so
i tried working at music plus and i'll
tell you something i was
good at recommending movies and people
would come in and be like i saw this
movie and it has this guy in this house
i'd be like
this is the one you're talking about i
was good at my job well you're good of
course you're because you like
you're a curator you like to give people
advice
i was the host on turner classic movies
the essentials i know movies i love
movies whitney
oh my god whitney's losing it right now
um all right drew
you know everyone's on zoom these days
right so if you've ever been on a zoom
call and thought
you know if i just sit really still
maybe they'll like not notice that um
or they think i'm frozen and i can hang
up and like bounce
kind of like when you call someone on a
cell and you're like i can't i can't
what darn it and you just hang up
pretending like it's
i'm cutting out right now i can't
yes well if you've done that then you're
gonna love this the verge says you can
now download something called a
zoom escaper which is a program that
helps you secretly sabotage your video
calls
here's how it works you download it and
you set it up and then the next time
you're on a zoom you can click on it
to add like an annoying echo or make
your voice sound like you have a bad
connection
we actually have an example take a
listen i can add echo
my voice my voice so i can make you know
you know myself myself
so you could totally fake a technical
difficulty you can add a dog barking
jackhammer even a man weeping
for some reason that's true stories i
gotta go take care of this man who's
crying in my house
i wanna know would you try this or how
do you feel about zoom in general are
you over it
it you know we all have zoom fatigue
there's so many things that i think it
works better and more efficiently for
um but it is probably not for living
your entire life on
i'm not gonna lie i have faked the bad
signal
you have i have so you know maybe
listen listen it happens
sometimes you gotta go um
sometimes we all want a little extra raw
sauce though
on the news sandwich and guess what we
have a segment we're calling
the ross report okay it's the ross
report
yeah i'll have you know i wrote that
song too
uh all right so here's the deal ross
report i'm going to be bringing you
the full scoop on some stuff that's on
my radar and today we're going to do a
deep dive
on tj's i'm not talking tijuana trader
joe's
aegon it's a phenomenon it's been ranked
the top grocery store in the country by
consumers
there's always products trending there's
fans accounts trader joe's list is one
that people like they have 1.5 million
followers through
it's smaller than your average
supermarket but the special thing about
them is that 80
of their products are their private
brand they're good
and they're affordable you know i've
lost like almost 60 pounds in the past
year trying to cook for myself
and one of the things that i cook
literally four times a week
is uh tacos but i take out the tortilla
and instead i use this
jicama wrap now jicama is like that root
vegetable right
and tj sells them sliced like this thin
thin so it's almost like a lettuce wrap
they're they're cold it also has like a
little bit of a really nice like crunch
yes so here's what i do and i actually
have a choose your own adventure thing
over here of beans and guac and hot
sauce
i do black beans i cook them just with
whatever you want you can do
onions or garlic and then i do my
protein like
ground turkey with taco seasoning ground
chicken you could do salmon whatever
i love a taco seasoning uh-huh and then
a little hot sauce
and you're gonna love this so much
because
if you're trying to like um watch what
you're eating
you could have like eight of these which
i do like for dinner
and it's zero points or whatever wow
i have to say rossi your transformation
has been really extraordinary i mean
my daughter and i as you know all of um
who like always comes and checks you out
and is like
because she loves drag race and i'm
looking at even just the last season
and it's it's just your discipline my
goodness
well you know i i call it my recipes
recipes because i want it to taste
really good
um but i want it to be good for me and
you're trying that for the first time
can we talk about the jicama wrap
i was already a fan of jicama uh-huh but
a lot of the times i'll do tacos in
lettuce wraps
but it was a whole new ball game i have
to tell you
i'm obsessed with this so when i thought
what do i want to bring to the table at
jew's news for a ross report
i wanted to share with you something i
literally eat four or five times a week
so just try it okay well
i have to say as someone who is a major
fluctuator
yeah i'm on like the seesaw from hell
most of the time
there is a way that you can substitute
ingredients and make
life really fun while you eat healthy
diets are something that anyone is going
to rebel against after a while
part of our pleasure in life is food
you cannot eat chicken and broccoli for
the rest of your life it just doesn't
work and it's going to make you
go off the rails so you've got to find
these like great alternatives and
they're out there
and they have to be fun that's why i
like this is something so basic then you
can mix up what you put in it
every single night it can be different
well you know how much we love curating
and just trying to bring new
ideas and things to people's lives so
this is brilliant well the stuff you
bring me in the doggy bag i literally
bring home and try and use so i just
want to contribute back to you
[Music]
well